here in this video we will discuss and
showcase to you guys a comparison
between the crocodile kaiju from the
movie rampage and the deadly skull
crawler from the movie kong skull island
we are also going to pit them against
each other assessing their size powers
abilities etc in order to know who will
come out on top in a fight between these
two crawling reptilian kaiju so before
we go deeper into this video do remember
to hit that subscribe button to be a
part of our mind cue family and now
let's compare these two pretty monsters
so let's start with the origins lizzy
who is never addressed to by her name
appears in the 2018 rampage movie she is
an american crocodile that gets
converted into a giant monster after
ingesting a mutagenic canister that fell
from the energized space station in her
everglades home the skull crawler
however is an ancient hyper-carnivorous
subtitan species that appears first in
the movie gong skull island and also
later in godzilla vs kong the species
lives in the hollow earth and also at
times make their way up to the surface
of the planet in skull island
so let's discuss the differences in body
structure and design instead of being a
dinosaur-like monster lizzie is a
mutated crocodile she possesses
elephant-like tusks on her upper jaw
then a spike covered tongue numerous
rows of razor sharp teeth fish like
gills on her neck a neck fill that she
can open when threatened and rows of
enormous spines running down her back
her tail is likewise covered in enormous
spikes that form a giant tail-like club
she also has large sharp clawed
gecko-like feet
skull crawlers however are huge reptiles
having just two long full limbs
no hind limbs whatsoever and long
prehensile serpentine tails their bodies
are long and slim
powerful and sturdy several features of
their appearance particularly their
torsos and skulls are very clearly
skeletal in design their jaws include
two rows of serrated razor sharp teeth
and their heads resemble those of mosses
like the tylosaurus each hand of the
skull crawlers have four clawed digits
in total
now let's compare their sizes their
length height and weight lizzie is
around 60 meters or 200 feet long the
giant skull crawler is also close to
that at 194 feet long what about the
height well many estimates put lizzy at
around 15 to 18 meters or 50 to 60 feet
tall while the big skull crawler is said
to be 95 ft tall but most of the time it
hunches down and crawls and therefore
looks to be around 60 feet itself the
weight of these two mosses will
determine which one has a mass advantage
lizzie is officially 150 tons while the
skull crawler is 33 percent lighter at
100 tons in weight
let's compare their abilities now both
these monsters were invulnerable to
small arms fire and were both able to
withstand 50 caliber machine gun fight
at them
so we can say that they were both very
durable and armoured in a way lizzie was
able to withstand anti-tank missiles
fired from a down apache helicopter
those ones call the hellfire missiles if
i'm not mistaken but the big one was
hurt by a flare although to its defense
it was fired directly at its eye but
anyhow i would say that lizzie had
thicker armor and was more durable
both these monsters don't have any fire
breathing abilities or any kind of
ranged weapons like beams or
lighting attacks or anything of that
sort
they were both hyper carnivorous though
with the skull crawlers taking the lead
in this field since its biology makes it
live in a state of constant starvation
the skullcrawler was also faster and had
a prehensile tail that it can use to
grab things with
on the other hand lizzy had a club-like
tail with spikes that it can use to
impale enemies lizzie also had the upper
hand in his bite force that was shown to
be able to rip a giant wolf's head clean
off of its body one advantage that the
skullcrawler might have is its
intelligence it was malicious and was
able to know what the soldier was
thinking you know the one soldier that
planned to be eaten with a pack of
grenades so that he could kill the
skullcrawl from inside but the
skullcrawler just killed him with his
tail swinging him into the air and then
he exploded
so what about their enemies we should
know what they were fighting against and
how they fight
both of them face a giant ape as their
main rival in the case of lizzy it was
george the giant white gorilla and in
the case of the skull crawler it's kong
the eighth wonder of the world
george was around 40 to 50 feet tall in
the movies while kong was 104 feet tall
both of these apes had a hard fight on
their hands against these giant reptiles
but it was very obvious that kong was
taller than scott crawler and george was
way smaller than lizzie in their battles
george was completely outmatched and the
only way he secured a win was with a
lucky strike impaling lizzie through the
eye with a metal bar
and on the other hand gorm and the skull
crawler were roughly equal in strength
battling each other throwing each other
around and and comb was able to kill it
by ripping out its guts clean through
its mouth
so let's see the results both monsters
are very similar in height and length
but the giant crocodile takes the lead
with weight as it was 50 tons heavier it
was also able to withstand anti-tank
weapons therefore making it more heavily
armoured
the skullcrawler was seen to be more
vicious and cutting therefore getting a
point in intelligence it was also faster
and more agile able to jump and run
towards kong in a very shocking manner
but this will not do well with a
crocodile that has a fatal set of
weapons which are its jaws and its spiky
club-like tail the skull crawler even if
it was able to dodge the tail and the
mouth would be unable to bite through
the tough height of lizzie while lizzie
can clearly decapitate her opponent
so lizzy takes the win in a battle
against the skull crawler it could have
been a tough fight but in the end the
subtitle wouldn't have been able to sing
its teeth deep enough and with that we
come to the end of the video of the
comparison of the skullcrawler versus
lizzie the crocodile do hit that like
button for support and smash that
subscribe button to be a part of our
mind cue family also hit that bell
button for regular updates on new videos
till the next one take care fam